Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
Marvel just released a new X-Men Teaser
there was a special livestream event
where they revealed what's going on.
They're doing brand new episodes on Disney
Plus, too, so we'll break it all down.
Cyclops, I know how you feel
about it, Wolverine, but
you know that little man.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I will do new episodes of the series
when it starts later this year.
It is one of the new Marvel Disney
Plus series
that they are still doing this year,
even though they've delayed
a lot of things.
Right now, they're getting for
a big anniversary for the original series.
It sounds like they're timing the release
of the new episodes
to coincide with that anniversary.
All this going on while they're
introducing mutants again to the MCU
or revealing that new ones have been there
this whole time, like we just saw
No more during Black Panther.
What kind of forever?
He's been a mutant living in the MCU
for hundreds of years.
They just introduced Ms..
Marvel and canonized her as a mutant
inside the MCU.
They even played X-Men, the Animated
series theme song during the last episode
when they were talking about her
being a mutant.
There's something different in your genes,
like like a mutation.
They also just use Patrick Stewart
as a version of Professor
X based on the one from X-Men.
The animated series with that
yellow floaty chair is part of the A38
Illuminati inside Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness. Oh,
my final member,
Professor Charles Xavier.
I love the way that Marvel has been
using the X-Men, the animated series theme
song for all their mutants so far
inside the MCU the last couple of years.
But if it wasn't clear during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness
that version of Patrick Stewart,
Professor X is meant to be a completely
different version from his original Fox
Marvel X-Men character and from X-Men
the Animated Series.
They just said he was meant to be
a totally new version of the character
based on the one from X-Men,
the animated series,
the brand new episodes
that they're doing on Disney.
Plus later this year for X-Men 97,
as they're calling it,
basically like the continuation of X-Men,
the animated series,
like Season six of the actual series,
just picking up where they left off.
They just had a big X-Men
60th anniversary livestream
where a bunch of creators
talked about the comics,
people talked about the series,
the movies, all that stuff.
And during that Bow, DiMeo,
who's the showrunner
for these brand new X-Men episodes, talked
about what the plot is going to be,
and we found out a little bit more
about what their plans are for the series.
In general,
the really good news
is that it sounds like
they actually planned for it
to run up to four seasons.
We've
heard all about all these cancellations
and delays of all these big Marvel series
and Marvel movies.
But it does sound like
they've had big plans for X-Men
and they're continuing those.
Pretty much all the cast
of the original series came back.
They're already starting work on season
two right now of that revival.
And in the new synopsis that
the showrunner revealed, he said that Mr.
Sinister is going to be the main villain.
It says Storm and Cyclops
try to continue the X-Men.
Magneto comes in
and wants to step up for Charles Xavier
because obviously he's left with Landro.
Mr. Sinister comes in and tries
to end the X-Men once and for all.
Back at Comic-Con
we did get a first look for the series.
This is just some of the designs
they're using,
basically, like a nicer, shinier version
of the original design.
So it'll feel like a true continuation
of the old episodes
within the live action movies.
They've been developing an X-Men movie
in the background this whole time,
and even though Kevin Foggy implied
that we'll see more of them sooner
rather than later, he didn't want to wait
that long before introducing them.
We're getting Deadpool three
where Deadpool and Hugh Jackman Wolverine
from those Fox X-Men movies is coming
back.
Hi. Hi.
How are you?
You have questions? Yes,
I had a lot of questions.
I'm sure you had a lot of questions.
But rest assured,
we're going to answer them right now.
There's meant to be like the tip
of the iceberg during Marvel Phase six.
It's like an early Marvel Phase six movie.
And then I think what they're going to do
is they'll introduce more mutants
during Marvel Phase six
and then after Secret Wars,
they'll fix the universe.
Like after we talk about Qing Dynasty,
secret wars,
where they collapse the multiverse,
do a version of Battle world,
use the Secret Wars movie as a swan song
to all those Fox Marvel movies.
The Fox Fantastic Four movies,
the old Sony
Spider-Man movies like Tobey Maguire,
Andrew Garfield's movies.
Then when they fix the multiverse
and everything goes back
to the way it was, they fix things
in a slightly different way with a couple
of minor changes
that explain how mutants are everywhere.
Now, with the whole Scarlet Witch joke,
with the reverse house of M, lots
more mutants and Scarlet,
which was forced to take action,
whispering the words
No more new techniques.
And then Marvel Phase seven
will be the beginning of a hardcore X-Men
saga of movies like the next couple phases
after Marvel's Multiverse saga,
which we're in the middle of right now.
Like after Phase six,
we begin a bunch of core X-Men stuff.
The funny reason
why they waited so long on that too, like,
why didn't they just start doing
X-Men stuff right away?
Because it does feel a little like Marvel
Phase four, Marvel Phase five Marvel.
Phase six people had a lot of complaints,
especially about Marvel Phase four.
Like, why do you feel like you're spinning
your wheels so much?
Marvel I have a feeling after the fact,
after everything goes down, we get past
Avengers Secret Wars into Marvel.
Phase seven
People will feel like the multiverse saga,
like these three phases
will be the phase where we were
just waiting for X-Men to show up.
The saga of movies
where we wanted to see more X-Men.
Thank you, Kevin.
Foggy Love you, Kevin. Foggy
Thank you. MCU.
The funny thing about that
is there's actually a rumor
that there's a contractual issue
that's preventing Kevin Figure
in the Marvel
people from doing legit X-Men the way that
they wanted to do them for a long time.
Now, supposedly when Disney bought Fox
and got the rights to all those X-Men
Fantastic Four characters back, supposedly
there were contracts in place
with all that Fox stuff
that prevented them from recasting
some of those actors until beyond 2025.
Now, there've been a couple of delays
with Marvel movies,
Marvel, Disney Plus series.
They've changed their release schedule,
so we're not getting quite as many things
quite as fast as they originally planned
a couple of years ago.
But that would explain
why Marvel has pulled the taffy just taken
so long in
introducing more core X-Men characters.
Like we've seen mutants start to pop up,
but as far as I can remember,
they haven't used the word X-Men inside
any of the live action
movies or the new live action movies
so far, the plan
gave me wings on my ankles and ears
that pointed to the clouds.
It was a mutant, but the cool thing is
there are a lot of Easter eggs for them.
Setting up big X-Men ideas
during Marvel Phase five and Marvel Phase
six with Val, for instance,
like Val Thunderbolt Ross being the reason
for the creation of a lot of these things.
Really good example
that is the Sentinel program.
So a lot of people have seen in
Black Panther what kind of forever?
Val basically
becomes the director of the CIA in Marvel.
Phase
five in general is meant to be sort of
like a dark reign type of era
in Marvel history.
Thunderbolt
Ross is supposed to become President
of the United States
by Captain America Four New World
Order in the Thunderbolt Movie.
That's like the end of Marvel Phase five.
The whole idea is that during
Captain America four
in Thunderbolts, supposedly
they're going to be using to emit
from the Eternals movie that did Celestial
in the Indian Ocean, finally paying off
that Easter egg and saying that that's
where adamantium comes from.
And out of that,
that Val is going to be responsible now
for the weapons plus program where she is
also responsible for the Weapon
X program, which is where you get
to the new MCU version of Wolverine.
Now they're doing Hugh Jackman Wolverine
before that happens,
before they introduce a new MCU Wolverine.
But also they have the new Iron Man
Armor Wars movie that's coming out.
A lot of people have theorized
they're actually changing the plot
just a little bit
because obviously Rhodey
is going to be a much bigger character
and they'll use
some slightly different villains
because during the Armor Wars movie,
Iron Man winds up fighting the government.
Obviously, Robert Downey Junior,
Iron Man is dead in the MCU right now.
See the picture war machine
getting a lot of that storyline,
war machine fighting the government
who is now Val in Thunderbolt
Ross, basically
because he's become the president
of the United States where they co-opt
stark tech and build their own
giant armor suit,
which is called firepower in.
While that's going on in the background,
they use that stark tech to try and create
a new version of a central program.
So like in the MCU, Val will be
responsible for the Sentinel program.
So you can see in the background
how they're slowly
setting the stage with a lot of these
big trappings of X-Men series
where you have sentinels,
you have mutants popping up everywhere,
and obviously it's all going to be tied to
what happens during secret wars.
So while they're doing swan songs
for a lot of these legacy, Fox
Marvel characters like Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine, don't be surprised
if in the background
you start to see other mutants
start popping up
like other big characters.
Also really good news.
Talking about more X-Men stuff
coming back,
Patrick Stewart made it sound like
he and Ian McKellen are both coming back
as their characters as Professor
X and Magneto during Deadpool three.
Those will be a lot of cameos
from the Fox Marvel movies during that two
now picture date.
But everyone wants this shift
because it sounds like they're waiting
till the end of this year,
like October at the earliest
for these new X-Men episodes.
I don't expect to get any kind
of official trailer for that
until way later this year, but maybe
we'll get some footage, some teasers.
Of course I'll do new videos and I will do
episode videos for all of them.
When it does come out.
Right now,
the report is they actually plan on
doing four new seasons of it
instead of doing like two or three
as they're doing for the
What If series supposedly.
What if it's going to end
after season three?
If you have any more questions about X-Men
or other related stuff in the MCU,
just write up below in the comments.
And of course I'll do videos
as we get new footage and Easter eggs.
Everyone click here for that brand new
Iron Man Armor Wars First Look and Cooking
for My New Mandalorian Season
three Episode five Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.